what is the best tablet in the world is  it apple with their m1 ipad pro or is it  samsung with their brand new galaxy tab  s8 ultra well today we will find out  once and for all in this detailed  comparison where we're going to compare  the displays the speakers the  performance of the cpu and graphics and  more and honestly once we've seen the  performance we saw how the screen  compares i think that even android  fanboys  have to admit that the ipad with the m1  is the king of all tablets not only do  you have that 1600 nits display you also  have the better speakers we have  the cameras that are better on the back  with lidar you also have incredible  performance the storage  it is a nice nice machine it's just a  shame that apple limits ipad os so much  it has so much potential  but  they still want you to buy a macbook